[Music]
Here We Go Again Sony have fully
revealed the free games will receive as
ps+ essential subscribers for the month
of February 2024 the following games
will be available from the first Tuesday
of the month that's February 6th please
do me a favor and leave a like to
support this series and maybe a comment
too game one is Roller Drome and it's a
great game so please don't let the
visuals throw you off if you're not a
fan of cell shaded graphics on both PS4
and PS5 roller Drome is essentially Tony
HW box with guns we done roller skates
and are pushed into an arena filled with
bad guys ready to take us out we then
travel around at speed dodging bullets
and perfecting combos clearing the stage
as quickly as possible our Arsenal
starts with basic pistols and over the
campaign more become available like
grenade launchers and for those with
more precise aim a rail gun is here too
the tricks you pull off are not simply
for show or for that combo they are also
how we refill ammo forcing players to
perfect both sides of the game the local
motion and the shooty shooty bang bang
and thanks to this cool slow motion
mechanic taking out your foes always
feels amazing reviews average out at 8
out of 10 and I definitely recommend it
please give it a try next up is steel
Rising an action RPG set in Paris during
an alternative version of the French
Revolution in this timeline there's a
robot army in control the King has gone
a little bit too far and Unleashed his
Clockwork automatons on the residence
and now we must fight back set in third
person still Rising is definitely a
soulslike game it's combat focused and
tough a single player grind till the end
that will inevitably force you to throw
a controller or two in Anger the
campaign is around 16 hours long and
you'll work with Marian twet no less to
take down the Mad King and should you
lose in a battle you'll also lose all
the souls you've collected I mean all
the anima Essence you've collected so
far it's the risk reward we're so used
to with this type of genre reviewers say
there's some good ideas in here but the
combat is a little bit too basic average
review score is just under 7even out of
10 so will you try it before the final
game an extra for you fall guys players
you'll have access to a ton of
PlayStation focused Cosmetics including
aloy a nice little extra indeed and
finally a familyfriendly party shooter
form stars on both PS4 and PS5 a brand
new 4 on four bubble battler that is a
PlayStation exclusive the battlefield
can be covered in bubbles and surfing on
your team's color grants a speed boost
whereas moving on the opponent's color
slows your players down but bubbles do
pop and vanish over time shaping the
landscape is a key skill to Master on
the Weaponry side each of our foam Stars
has their own choice of blasters from
Dual pistols to full-on Cannons of foam
which then shape their play style along
with their abilities and how they best
complement other teammates characters
there'll be three PVP and one PVE game
mode at launch rubberduck party is foam
star's escort Mission as a huge rubber
duck is pushed forward to the goal or
whoever gets it the furthest in the time
period claims the win smash the star is
the Deathmatch Style game mode but after
seven eliminations one opponent is made
into a juggernaut with extra health and
damage output to act like an end boss
and also give their team a chance to
catch up did you get this far in the
video is f Stars the hero shooter you
never knew you wanted or will you pass
this one by I'm down to make some
character guides if foam Stars Finds Its
audience so that's our games for
February please let me know what you
think in the comment I'm Adam you're
awesome it's been a pleasure T
to